翻訳: Mika Ikeda
校正: Hiroko Kawano
（音楽）
（音楽 終わり）
[Value 価値とは]
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
あれ マイク入ってるかな？
今日はみなさんに
ちょっと考えていただきたいな
と思うことがあるんです
今日 あなたが新しく
ベッドのマットレスを買おうと思いました
１つは１万円ぽっきり
もう１つは
ホテルライフのような10万円のマットレス
どちらを購入されますか？
もしかしたら 「私は 美容に良いから
睡眠はすごく重視したいの
だから高くても10万円の
マットレス買うわ」っていう方も
この中にいらっしゃるんじゃないでしょうか
価格 みなさんの個々の判断によって
プライスレスになっていくものだと
思うんですね
今日 そのベッドのマットレス
家に届きました
今まで使っているベッドの
マットレス 不要です
「どうしたらいいのかなぁ」と思って
業者さんに聞きました
A社さんに聞いたら 処理するのに５千円
石坂産業に聞いたら ７千円って言ってます
さあ みなさん
どちらの会社 選びますか？
「不要な物にお金を払いたくない」
多くの人が そう 今 一瞬
考えられませんでしたか？
ちょっと見ていただきたいんですが
年間に排出される
各国の一般廃棄物の量です
一般廃棄物とは
私たちが生活の中で
出している廃棄物のことですね
ここには載っていない国もあります
だいたい日本はですね
およそ５千万トンの
生活の廃棄物を出しています
これ １人当たりの―
１年間の量に換算しますと
およそ１人 365キロ
年間排出していることになります
この量って多いですか？
それとも 少ないと思われますか？
こちらはですね
その各国の生活の廃棄物が
どう処理されているかを
示しているグラフです
ぱっと見て 紺色のグラフ
色が濃いですよね
これ ほとんどの廃棄物が
そのまま埋め立てされている
という状況です
出た廃棄物をほとんど埋め立て
してしまっている国もありますよね
ちょっと どれも色が同じようにしか
私には見えないんですけど
みなさん どうです？
見えてますか？
実は日本はですね
「焼却」におよそ75%
使ってるんですよ
日本は国土がたいへん狭いですから
埋め立てすることが
ごくごく僅かになっていますね
ほとんどを焼却に頼っている
という状況なんです
では そのうち―
戦後ずっと排出されている
産業廃棄物の量はどのぐらいか
おおよそ 年間４億トンという
産業廃棄物が出ています
産業廃棄物といっても
私たち経済活動 事業活動
もっともっとより豊かな社会になるように
新しいものをどんどん
作ろうとすればするほど
出てくる廃棄物が産業廃棄物です
それが４億トン
東京ドームの容量で言うと
だいたい1100杯分ぐらい
年間に出しているというような
イメージになるんですね
この産業廃棄物の処理をしているのが
この私の仕事です
全国におよそ１万８千社程度の
こういった産業廃棄物を
受け入れする会社がございます
もし あなたの家の 住まいの近くに
この産業廃棄物の処理施設が
できると思ったら
どういうふうに感じられますか？
Not In My Back Yard
（自分の家の裏庭にあってほしくないもの）
NIMBY（ニンビー）
私たちの仕事は
「迷惑産業」と言われています
私は小さい頃 父が始めた
この仕事なんですけれども
「ごみ屋の娘」
「あの子と遊ぶのはやめなさい」って
言われたことがあるんです
私の父がなぜ この仕事を始めたのか
私は父に聞きました
父はこう教えてくれました
「毎日毎日 海に運ばれていく
廃棄物を見て
まだまだ使えるものが たくさんあった
これから必ず リサイクルされる時代が来る
だから この仕事を始めたんだ」
というふうに 教えてくれたんです
ところが1999年のときに
ダイオキシンの報道があったのを
みなさんご存知でしょうか？
このことによって
私の会社は埼玉の所沢
という所にあるんですけれども
地域の方たちから「迷惑な会社だ」
「とにかく出て行ってくれ」
「不要な産業なんだよ」
というようなことを―
多くの人たちから言われる
結果になりました
せっかく父が世の中のために
良かれと思って始めたこの仕事が
多くの人たちが
不要な産業だと思っている
しかし みなさんに
考えていただきたいんです
誰がこの廃棄物を
出しているんですか？
この廃棄物を いったい誰が
どこで片付ければいいんですか？
これを考えていかなくては
ならないのは
私たち一人ひとりの
使命だということを
決して忘れないで
いただきたいなと思うんです
私はここで働く人たちの姿を見て
毎日毎日 多量に
たくさんのダンプで運ばれる
廃棄物の中に手を入れて
いる物・いらない物
一生懸命分けている彼らの姿を見て
「これは日本の宝だ」というふうに
私は思いました
そして 父の仕事を初めて誇りに思う
きっかけにもなったことです
では私たち
この産業廃棄物処理から
いったい何を新たに生み出せるのか
私の会社は およそ東京ドーム
3.5個分の面積があります
そのうちの２割が
廃棄物の処理工場です
８割は里山保全活動をしています
今は全国 そして世界から
たくさんの 多くの人たちが訪れ
そして廃棄物の処理の 今後の在り方
そして地域にこのような施設があったら
どういうことが起きるのか
また これから地球の環境を
どうしていくことで
保全していくことができるのか
多くのみなさんに「考える機会」を
与えさせていただいています
ぜひ考えていただきたいと思うんです
私たちの このような迷惑施設が
どうしたら今の状況から
今のことから
新たな価値産業を
生み出すことができるのか
新しいものは 全て今無いものから
作り出すことばかりではなくて
今「現状にあること」を
変えていくということも
非常に大切なことではないかな
というふうに思っています
今 私たちの会社で働く人たちや
また これからこの廃棄物の
処理の仕事を続ける人たちが
夢や誇りを持って 働けるような状況を
私たちが作っていかなくて
いったい誰に片付けてもらうんでしょうか？
「是非 多くの方たちにこの廃棄物のことを
考えてもらえるきっかけが作れた
私の役目は意味があるのかな」
そういう想いで 今
会社の社長をやらせてもらっています
みなさんは将来
そしてこれから未来に向けて
廃棄物で土壌が汚染され
森や川がどんどん荒廃化した
砂漠のような地球に
住みたいと思われますか？
それとも 自然と共生し
森や水が豊かな地球環境で
これから生活していきたいと思いますか？
これを今 選択するのは
私たち一人ひとりの使命であると
みなさんが選んでいく時代に
なっていると思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）